[拍手]
皆さんはじめまして
本日はですね演劇速日常のススメということで演劇のことを話させていただこうと思い
ます池田 revo と言いますよろしくお願いします
とまっ坂野ねー
すいません
を出ましたねはい申し訳ないです駅だけこと申しますもう一度よろしくお願いします
私はですねあの連合という名前でやらせていただきまして
まあのレバーブロックのレポートも結構親和性の高い名前であればの本来
デンマーク語でよく遊べというものの役所をみたいなんですね
ですから僕は演劇を教えてるんですけど演劇っていうのは
遊びなのでまぁレゴブロックのレゴでもいいのかなと歯を持ってるんですけど
でまぁ池田レゴガレージという野望でワークショップを開催させていただいたり自由
大学という間社会人大学で
橋上させて頂いたり桑沢デザイン研究所というところでね
デザインの学生を相手にゲスト講師をやらせたりやらさせていただいたりしております
入った僕が何を教えているのかというと
演劇を教えているんですよね
演劇です
だいたいね演劇を教えてるって言うとほとんどの人が俳優向けにぎし通している人だっ
て皆思うんですよ僕はね
社会人向けの演劇活用法を教えているっていうねちょっと特殊な先生になります
で自己紹介のときに皆さんにご名刺渡して社会人向けに演劇を教えてますと言うと
だいたい民のねこういうんですよ
演劇が何の役に立つんですか
1ないですよね
あの演劇っていうのは実は凄い異論が役に立つんですけれどもほとんどの方って演劇と
日常生活がどうつながるかが全く分からない
人が本当に多いです
今日私はですねこの演劇がどういう風にして役に立つのか
その演劇のススメっていうのを18分間ちょっとお話させていただこうと思っています
今で2分ですねはい
でまぁそれ話すためにちょっと自分のちょっとしたストーリーから話させていただこう
と思うんですけど私はですね
1977年に奈良県で生まれました
結合の生涯どもり症ってやつですね石綿障害人と話すと真っ赤になってしまう
そういうのがあって大寸恐怖症だったんですね小学生の時です
こういう状況の人間って多分にもれずいじめられっ子なわけですよ
まあいじめられるいじめられる殴る蹴るは当たり前です
まあ給食に唾が入ってたりねある日ね家に帰ろうと思ってカバンをね持とうと思ったら
何近所で繋がれてたことありましたからねかバーンと大津区矢田南近所でつながれる
舞台なこともあったんですけどまぁ虫とかもね普通にされるような本当にいじめられと
でした
でも人が好きだったんですねとにかく友達欲しかった
いじめ来られこの友達しかいなかったんですけど普通お友達が欲しかったんですよ
でも僕の友達って本でした本しか友達なかった
当時読んでた本が江戸川だんっ
コナンというモーリスルブラン皆さんしてますかね江戸川乱歩って言ったらええ
少年探偵なんですコナンドイルはあの有名なシャーロックホームズですよね
モーリスルブランでしてますか知ってる人を気をあげてください
ちらほらいるねルパン3世ですあるたんだ
アルセーヌルパン方です三平のほうじゃないねうんある程度たんですね
ねそういう探偵小説がすごい好きですごい読んでたんですね
僕将来は名探偵になるって決めてました
名探偵になってたくさん事件を解決するんだってずっと思ってたんですね人とほとんど
つながりが持てなかったのでで小学校3年生の時にルパン3世のカリオストロの城って
いうのを見ますみなさんしてますか入庁
ねめっちゃいい話でしょ姉めっちゃ感動したんですよ
小3の僕はあの子
大タワーの上からねルパンが数を抜いてきて
で
kreis 金だねって聞いたら泥棒です入ってるところがあるじゃないですか
もうめちゃくちゃかっこよくて俺絶対将来大泥棒になろうと思うんですね
小学校三年生です
まあ悩むんですよ
いいですか
大泥棒と喫茶店は擁立できるんですキャッツアイとかそうですからね
でもね
大泥棒と名探偵って一緒にできないんですよ
だって僕捕まえろっていうのが僕のに嫌い入ったらもうどうしようもないじゃないです
か
でどう思ったかというとこれ役者やったら両方できるんちゃう
で小3の時に思ったんです
しかも逆所だったらいっぱい
たくさんしゃべることができるからコミュニケーションの練習にもなってもしかしたら
友達もできるんじゃないかそう考えまして
まあ小学校3年生7歳の時に学校で劇団を作ります
いじめこの友達をみんな誘って敵弾作ろうよ言って学校
この先生に源家喜劇でも作ったのでもうちょっとこういう高いですね省理由とか
結局劇団を作ってもらっハピこの満福くださいって言いに行くわけです
でっ
最初の舞台を小学校のお楽しみ会で踏んだのが7歳のときになります今僕は38歳ので
そっから31年間本当にね
まっ僕の日常はずーっと演劇漬けの日常を過ごしていくんですね
まあその後ですねじゃあどういう風にして演劇開けたらどうなったのかと言うとまず小
学校の時に演劇を続けることで緊張と仲良くなってね
どもりしょうがなくなったんですよ関明障害もなくなって人と話せるようになりました
中学校の頃にはもういじめもなくなって友達ができました
ん
方向今度はね慕ってくれる後輩とか友人もできたんですね
で大学は北近畿大学の演劇芸能学科っていうところでね
通ってたんですけれども
当時二十歳です二十歳の時に自分で劇団をつくって地元でやってたんです
皆さんお芝居観に行ったことはありますかねお芝居もに行くとアンケートってのを書き
ますね
僕あのアンケートにね自分の作出演 a
a 室でやった芝居のアンケートにこんなジャケットだったんですよ
最近生きてても面白くないっ
毎日毎日同じことの繰り返しで私はもう死のうと思ってます
って書いてあるんですアンケート
でも
友達に無理やり引きずられてあなたたちの芝居を見に行きましたっ
もうちょっと生きていてもいいなって思いました
したな子でしたね本当にありがとうって書いてあったんですね
まあ嬉しかったですね涙が止まらなくなっちゃってね取り方が当たっては演劇って
すごいなぁと思ったんですよ
あの僕自身が演劇で人生を救われたんですね
その僕が演劇を使って少しでも人に勇気を与えることができた
希望を与えることができたっていうのがまあとにかく嬉しくてもっと
大学行ってる場合じゃないと思ってもう2体届を出して上京してくるんですね
東京に来てで劇団始めるんです
で劇な初めて初めはねあの
劇団をやって劇団の運営で食べていくってことができるようにはなったんですけれども
結婚しましてねで今妻もいるんですけどこの中に結婚して一に立ったら食べていける
けど二人じゃ食べていけなくなっちゃうわけですよ
じゃないからちょっと劇団は劇団でやりながらどっかで派遣で仕事を始めようかと
当時ねあの新宿の方にあるとある瓜田量販店で派遣で営業の仕事を始めるんですね
なんですけど私仕事まったくできないんですよ
なにせねこっちに汎用になりに生きている演出作家になりに来てるんで
そんな仕事僕のすることで内の営業なんてだからこんなんやってる場合ちゃうわーって
思ってたんで
まあ店長には厳しく与えられるし
しょっちゅう首の憂き目になってましたでも結構もしてるしねこのままじゃあな
まずいなぁと
思ってでも仕事は俺劇ないなぁ
と思いましてどうしたかっていうとよし
職場で稽古しようって思うんですよ
演劇の稽古しようお仕事はできないでも演劇だったらできる演劇の傾向をしようと思っ
て職場でうん劇の傾向を始めたんですね
そしたら成績にどんどんはだったんですよ
本当にトップになりましたその
ぶっ
なんだよねはい
日前上反転でトップまでなったんですねはい今のこれでお願いしますねはいそれでです
ね
まああの
その時に思ったのが演劇ってすごいなぁとこれ僕の力ちゃうんです演劇の力よと思った
んです
あこれはこの演劇の力って役者だけで独占するのはあまりにももったいない
日本の人にもっとこの演劇の凄さというのを伝えていこうって私は布団で深く思いまし
て
今社会人に演劇を教える仕事をしています
えっ
最初の表題に戻りますけどこの日常で演劇を使っていこうというのが演劇速日常のス
メっていう今回の私のタイトルになるんですね
でじぇ演劇で何をしていくかというと基本的にはこの想像力
イマジネーションっていうのと表現弱パフォーマンス能力
この2つを磨いていきます
ん
想像力が磨かれると自分らしく生きる力になります
そして表現力が磨かれるとこの自分らしさを生かす力になっていくんですね
でこの2つを磨いていくことでどんどんどんどんね
自分が人と関わり合いが人と関われるようになっていくんです
まぁ簡単に言うとコミュニケーション能力が非常に向上します
あの
例えばですよ舞台って
同じ共演者と普通にコミュニケーションをとるわけですよね
要するにこれをカンバセーション会話力
2位のその流れをそのまま会話をしながら進行してお客さんに説明していくわけですよ
ね
説明振興局ですねでそれでお客さんを最後盛り上げて感動させるというのはプレゼン
スピーチ力なんですよ
つまり演劇の中にはコミュニケーションも全てが詰まっているんですね
でっ
こんなすごいものを
曲日本人が知らないので
一人でも多くの人に演劇の凄さを伝えてまずこのコミュニケーション能力を磨いて
もらおうというのでやってるんですけれども
例えば
一番よくどこだ言っているのが
表現力っていうのには2種類の表現がありますよと言葉による表現と言葉でない非言語
の表現がありますよで話すことと聞くことっていうのは2つありますよね
でよくね
着方教室とか行くとどういう風にしてその聞いていることをイメージするかというのを
教えてもらえるんですよ
でもねぇ
大切なことって
聞いて理解する力より
いいてるよアピールなんですよねうん
めっちゃ効いているよう私っていうアピールができなかったら結局との日と聞いてると
思ってもらえないんですよ
これ演劇なんですけどで例えばハギュット
ブロードウェイあります米ブロードウェーの演劇って世界一だって言われるんです
でその理由っていうのはブロードウェイの役者が世界一だからじゃあないって言うん
ですね
ブロードウェイの観客が世界一だからなって言うんです
すごいリアクションをしてくれるし全力で拍手をしてくれるし
スタンディングオーベーションですが今日もやっていいんですよあと3人表べーしょん
だし
まあものすごく気持ちリアクションを観客が私てくれるからその分前に立ってる人間も
より腸走って
するんですね演劇っていうのはそういうのをもうしっかりヨンジ立てて学んでいくこと
ができます
まあ基本的にその話す聞く表現力というのは僕は相槌の力って言ってまして
あいうえおの法則って呼んでるんですけど相槌にうとえっとをがあるよと言うが動きだ
よと
しっかりと頷いた機構ねと絵が笑顔だよと基本笑顔で聞いていろんな表情を使って
いこうね
をが音声だよと
笑ったり大とかよねとこの3つ守るだけで実はものすごく人に疲れる
聞いている聴き方ができるんだよっていうのを
演劇を使って教えています
僕本屋とかに行くとそういう演劇以外の自己啓発とか
ビジネスとがいっぱい置いてあってそこに異論がうまくいくためのキップスとかスキル
がいっぱい書いてあるんですね
ただ
マインドセットって人を成長させないんですよ
あれ安心させるだけなんです読んでああなるほどこうすればいいんだわかった良かった
で終わるんですよ
動かないんですからで
人を成長させるのって体験だけなんですよ
実際にはインドセットで成長したと思っている人も
マインドセットを読んでああこういう風に自分がすればいいんだなって
実際動いたことで成長したんですね
行動しなきゃ意味ないんです役者というのは行動する人です
ですから英語でアクターと言います act って行動ですよね
でもあれ act ってただの行動じゃないんです tizen する行動なんです
改善行動のことを開くとって言いますだから役者っていうのは常に体験を常に改善し
続ける人のことなんですね
ですからぜ
んでその力を皆さんにも
見ていただきたいなぁと思うんですで演劇って
ロールプレイというものがありますからどんな体験でもできます
それこそ自分が今までやった事がよないような体験でも想像力を使えば全部
その場で体験できるんですねその体験っていうのは全部自分の力にしていけるし
全部
なんて言うんですかあの
うまくね人生を運んでいくための糧になるんですよ
僕はこの演劇っていうのを最強のソーシャルスキルトレーニングだと思っています
もちろん舞台に出るのは恥ずかしいかもしれませんがトレーニングだけだったらそこ
まで恥ずかしいことはないんですね
でそれを積み重ねていくことでコミュニケーションって本当にうまくなっていくんです
人材育成の人とかまあ教育関係の方にぜひ演劇というものを取り入れていただきたいと
思うんですね
ただ
日本の演劇支援っていうのは非常に
演劇の地位が低いです例えば私が
役者やってますっていうとこの人はどういうかというと何のテレビに出てるんですか
聞くんですね何の映画に出てるんですかって聞くんですよ
舞台ゲスって言うとアーてちょっとがっかりした顔するんです
だいたいするんです演劇って貧乏人のすみだと思われてるんですよ
けっこうな勢いで
でじゃあとも演劇ってどういうものなのかいうのをほとんど見たことないんです
激増行くの怖いから特にあの地下に行くようなね
ちー様市陶元できなんて強いから見たことないんですよ
ですからほとんど知られてないんです
演劇の活用法これは考えは結構ますとです
政治家経営者学校の先生
営業マン人に話すような仕事も人は大体一回円月学びます
演劇によって人にしっかりものを伝えていくスキルを磨くんですね
ただこの日本の小学校中学校には音楽美術はあっても学校教育に演劇っていう
ないんですよ
だから演劇ってすんごい支える力がものすごい入っているのに
誰も知らないし
貧乏人のすみだと思われですねどんどんどんどんね
なんか
追いやられてしまっているんですね
僕はこの日本の
円月演劇の力とかね
演劇の魅力演劇活用の力っていうのをたくさんの人にね
伝えていきたいと思っています
演劇ってこんなに使えるんだよって
いうのを知ってほしいんですね例えば演劇って体を使います本当に人間って笑顔の練習
を前にしているだけでコミュニケーションがどんどんうまくなっていくし
街を歩くときでもちょっと胸を張って早歩きで歩くだけで気持ちよくなってくるんです
だいたい人って落ち込むと肩を落として顔を下にしてゆっくり歩くんですけどこれを
意識的に胸を張って笑顔になって早足で歩く
これだけでいいんですこれだけで感情のコントロールまでできてしまうのが演劇の力で
もあるんです
そういったことを少しでも多くの人に知っていただいて
演劇の魅力や
演技活用の力を知ってほしいですねでっ
演劇の中にはたくさんの学びが入っていますでも演劇と基本遊びです
もともと大本が演劇って遊びなんです社会的な遊びと言われています
この遊びの中に実は大きな学びがあります僕はこれを池田で豪華な家って自分の野望の
スローガンとして演劇でまなぼっ
演劇で遊べば演劇で学べるしかも
演劇で後部ことで演劇で人とつながることもできるんですね
ですから演劇の力っていうのを一人でも多くの人に僕に語らせてください
あのぜひね
たくさんの人とつながりたいと思っているので演劇の力
もっと皆さんに知っていただきたいと思います本日はご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]